[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
in a series called High School memories
my name is cleab Gora and I will be your
host for today so without further ado
let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about the
benefit of learning a different language
enhance brain power learning a second
language is like a mental gym it
literally rewires your brain improving
cognitive skills memory and problem
solving abilities so if you're tired of
sodoku try learning a different language
communication
imagine being able to chat with people
from all around the world learning a
second language turns you into a bridge
between cultures and trust me it's not
just about for survival phrases you can
even order that coffee in another
language and impressible
baristo professional advances employers
love a bilingual candidate it's like
having an ace up your sleeve in a job
market you can communicate with
International clients
consider job opportunities in different
countries and also maybe you can get a
nice bonus on your
job cultural
appreciation when you learn a new
language you also dive into a new
culture it's not just about
understanding words it's about grasping
the Traditions history and a way of life
of the people who speak the language
this opens your mind to the beauty of
diversity and your
horizons personal growth learning a
second language can be a journey of
personal growth it's challenging no
doubt but if you conquer it your you
boost your selfesteem patience and
preservance it's not just about learning
a language it's about proving to
yourself that you can achieve what you
set your mind to lifelong learning the
quest of Master second language is a
lifelong Learning
Journey there's always something new to
discover whether it's sling or Regional
dialects it's a continuous adventure of
learning making life more exciting and
full of
surprises better decision making did you
know that learning a second language can
improve your decision- making skills
bilingual individuals tend to be better
at evaluating and weighing different
opinions this skill can be applied to
everything from everyday choices to Big
life
decisions global citizenship when you
learn a second language you become a
global citizen you gain a deeper
understanding of global issues engage in
cross-cultural conversations and become
a part of a worldwide dialogue it's like
becoming a citizen of the world where
it's more so borders and bridges rather
than
barriers think about it this way if you
were to go to a country and live there
for a couple of years maybe even decades
eventually you will pick up the language
maybe you don't even know it fluently
but you manage to decipher words and
have an understanding of them these are
the things that you need to know if
you're interested in learning a second
language but it's time to talk talk
about my experience trying to learn a
second language now I already know two
languages which is Albanian and English
but some people might consider that as
cheating because Albania is my native
language and English is the one other
language that I know of I started
speaking English at a very young age and
I grew up with it sometimes I'd speak it
a bit too much you could say but that's
how I got fluent at it besides English
I've been interested in other languages
such as Spanish and German I've tried
learning Spanish for the longest time
possible and let me just tell you it is
not easy you need serious dedication
serious motive in order to do it some
languages are easier than others but if
you don't speak a language no matter how
easy or hard it is it's going to sound
like gibberish to you and don't even get
me started on the grammar you can learn
how to say how are you hello
on almost every language but when it
gets to the grammar trust me we all have
those moments where we don't understand
what is going on now unlike Spanish I've
been learning German for 4 years since
it's a subject in school and honestly
with time I've come to understand
reading it like if a German person came
up to me right now and tried to hold a
conversation with me I'd only know how
to say so little but when I read a piece
of dialogue on a book I have some sort
of understanding of it see it's not easy
for you not to learn a language that
you've been learning for 4 years and who
knows maybe if I continue I could
possibly learn as a language languages
are very interesting to me the fact that
you can speak a language and no one else
understanding it is very overpowered cuz
you could say just about everything but
don't be rude because there is always a
possibility that they can speak it the
interesting thing about languages is
that a person doesn't have to look a
certain way in order to speak a language
it comes as a shock when you see someone
that's not from your country speak your
language and this is just about everyone
but it makes you proud in a certain way
just the thought that someone put their
effort into learning the language that
you speak and being able to communicate
with you is true effort now we've only
talked about people who know two
languages and although my entire topic
is about two languages I'd like to you
know add some more to it there are
people who know just as far as 20
languages maybe they aren't fluent but
when you speak it they can understand
what you're trying to say and maybe even
reply to you and that's
impressive one day I want to learn more
than the two languages I know right now
as I mentioned before I'm interested in
German and Spanish and I see them being
very useful as the points I made
before they could benefit you in
different sorts of ways imagine this
you're in a room with people you've
never met before and they mentioned
something about languages they start
speaking in their native tongue and all
of the sudden you understand what
they're trying to say you can contribute
to that conversation and when you reply
they will be shocked as ever
they could be amused by your skill and
you could leave a pretty good impression
every language takes time to learn but
with tons of patience and dedication you
can see yourself speaking that language
one day being able to speak it fluently
and it's like you never knew how to not
speak it phrases can be easier but you
can't avoid the grammar you need it
because when you speak you have to have
proper grammar of course
with all of that being said I hope I
motivated you to pick up a book and read
words that you don't understand until
you understand them the reason why I
chose this topic learning a second
language is very
impressive before we wrap it up here's a
quick language learning tip being
consistent is a key every day if you
practice your chosen language you can
just be amazed how far you've
come so thank you so much for joining us
on this episode of high school memories
it's been an incredible journey and
we're so glad you came along for the
ride until next time take
[Music]
care